you mentioned Tom Brady that obviously
is the biggest name for this free agency
class we still don't know where he's
gonna go although as of right now if I
were a betting man and I am NOT I would
say Tampa Bay is the new favorite in my
mind I don't see him staying with the
Patriots
I think the 49ers thing because it's
been so long since we've heard anything
I'm starting to get a feeling that one's
not gonna work out and the only team
that we've heard is actively pursuing
him and ready to go with the the cannon
ball in the cannon pun intended because
of that pirate ship they have down there
it's the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
so here's the thing though if we play
this out if we try to apply for site
instead of hindsight to this and we see
that free agency is going to be delayed
the offseason program will be smaller
than it otherwise would have been in
other years it reduces the opportunity
for Tom Brady to get to know new offense
new playbook new teammates new coaching
staff new city new everything does that
make him more inclined to stay put in
New England for one more year knowing
that there's a greater degree of
familiarity and you don't need all of
those things to get yourself ready to go
I'm starting to wonder whether or not if
we do see a reduced offseason program
that makes Tom Brady say maybe it's good
to do one more year and it makes the
Patriots extent they have reservations
about one more year with Brady and
specifically it would be coach Bill
Belichick say we're better off with the
guy who knows our system because we have
less of an opportunity to get a new guy
up to speed yeah I think it absolutely
does I think that if the offseason is
shorter and and we could learn any day
now or even any hour now oh that the NFL
is going to push back the start of the
league year and make the offseason
shorter I think every day that it's
shorter is another day that Tom Brady
thinks to himself I don't have enough
time to do this the right way because we
know if Tom Brady goes somewhere else he
is going to be highly motivated get it
right to learn his offense to get on the
same page with his receivers
you know to bring Alex Guerrero to town
and get workouts going with everybody on
the offense and showing them the
pliability and the t b12 method I mean
he he's gonna be all in if he goes
somewhere else he's not gonna be the guy
who signs somewhere else in this says
okay I'm skipping the offseason program
see you at training camp if he goes
somewhere else he wants to be all in and
he can't be all in if there is a cloud
of uncertainty over the offseason and we
don't even know when the offseason
program is going to begin so I think
that that this could really make a
difference and make him more likely to
stay with the Patriots which has been
you know it it certainly knows your
thing and you mentioned the Buccaneers
and I think there's a real possibility
of that you know Rick Stroud of the
Tampa Bay Times wrote something saying
the Buccaneers are going all-in on this
and you know he's Rick's John's been
covering the Buccaneers a long time he's
not a guy who just goes off with hot
takes someone in the organization has
told him we're ready to make an
aggressive move for Tom Brady and so we
know at least one place really wants Tom
Brady and that's a place with a lot more
cap space than the Patriots they'll be
able to offer him a lot more money and
so he's gonna have a good offer
whenever free agency starts and to the
extent that Tom Brady has grown weary of
Bill Belichick after 20 years of dealing
with doom and gloom talk about the exact
opposite Bruce Arians my goodness a
breath of fresh air as I said earlier
today on radio that breath may have a
little rum on it but it's still the
absolute 180-degree different coach than
Bill Belichick and it just makes a lot
of sense for something like that to
happen given that we are technically
only a few days away from the start of
free agency although I continue to
believe it's going to be bumped back the
Buccaneers are the team that that is the
only team that is being aggressively
linked to Tom Brady right now so that's
all subject to change because shorter
offseason
could push the Patriots and Brady back
together
the short offseason in 2011 with no
offseason program with free agency in
early August that was a year that the
Patriots went to the Super Bowl and they
benefited from the fact that there was
already that familiarity with the
offense
because the quarterback was the same
quarterback they had the year before and
they weren't breaking in a new one
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports